catherine guy a créé sa marque média et
médiation une micro entreprise
spécialisée dans l'édition du livre sur
la médiation en entreprise journaliste
salarié à temps partiel elle s'est
lancée dans l'auto entrepreneuriat pour
la simplicité du statut juridique
je savais que si je vendais rien je ne
paie rien aucune charge et si je vendais
je paierai les charges ce qui nous
paraissait simple et normale les auteurs
et les lecteurs prêts achète une
certaine quantité de livres ce qui me
permet d'avoir du cash pour pouvoir
payer mes fournisseurs
j'ai des revenus très variable avec
l'activité d'édition
je vous dire ça peut être autre en
taureaux 300 euros 3000 euros selon les
mois je paie mes charges paye mes
fournisseurs le paye mes auteurs mais je
ne paye pas encore moi-même dans son
projet catherine guy a été aidé par la
maison de l'entreprise de saint quentin
en yvelines
plusieurs types d'accompagnement à
travers des réunions de sensibilisation
et des rencontres individuelles avec des
experts un statut attractif notamment à
travers la flexibilité du plafond du
chiffre d'affaires nous avons environ
600 créations d'entreprises sur le
secteur de saint quentin en yvelines 600
créations par an et sur ses six ans nous
recensons environ 250 auto-entrepreneurs
l'auto entreprenariat c'est quelque part
une période d'essai
l'objectif pour nombre d'entre eux de
ces auto entrepreneurs
c'est à court ou moyen terme de
développer une entreprise dans un
contexte juridique classique plus de 13
mille entreprises ont été créées en 2016
dans le département des yvelines en
moyenne 40 % d'entre elles sont des
micro-entreprises